this is the Xbox one elite bundle and
its elite because it comes with the Xbox
one elite wireless controller so let's
see what this looks like it also has a
specialized hard drive inside the xbox
one we can't see that but I could talk
to you about it here's the bundle it is
five hundred dollars and you can kind of
see right off the bat front and center
is that xbox one controller which I
really liked and give me my full review
of the controller the xbox with a
terabyte solid-state drive for 500 bucks
okay on the left side of the box here
just your standard power supply and and
guts like that we've seen that a million
times before let's put this to the side
because come on you've done this before
all right I have an awful feeling the
console is just going to look like every
other xbox one we've ever seen but who
knows maybe it's special in some way
no it's not it's not really any
different I hate to disappoint everybody
yeah but what it does have on the inside
is special it's got a one terabyte solid
state hybrid drive so that's interesting
because that could potentially mean the
xbox one interface loads a little
quicker maybe gains load a little bit
quicker because solid-state drive allows
for caching and quicker access this up
so it's entirely possible again I have
not tested that out that is just
something I'm throwing out there it's a
possibility but that's really all you're
getting five hundred dollars you may not
hear that you're getting a lot of stuff
but again this is a hundred and fifty
dollars by itself and Xbox one with a
one terabyte drive usually goes for
roughly 400 bucks so in theory maybe
you're saving around fifty dollars with
this package there you have it the Xbox
one elite bundle I'm Jeff Bakalar as
watch
you